the craft beer movement in this country
has been powered by hops the flower that
gives beers like pale ales and IPAs a
wide range of delicious flavor the
American craft beer industry produces
just over 12% of the beer brewed in
America but it consumes a staggering 40%
of domestically grown hops about
three-quarters of which come from the
Yakima Valley in Washington State the
high desert has long days of sunshine
virtually no rain but access to water
from the Cascade Mountains perfect
conditions for hops farming and it's
where the country's top Brewers go every
September to personally shop for their
hops Dana Jacobson join them this is the
mecca of hops the Yakima Valley in the
heartland of Washington State home to
hops farms as far as the eye can see
each fall it's the destination of choice
for legions of craft brewers who make
their pilgrimage not for the sights but
for the sense like Sierra Nevada founder
Ken Grossman and a team of sent ologists
picked on the 4th of September correct
whoo we watched selecting some of this
year's crops were selecting over 50
different varieties with unique
aromatics Meghan pelts has a master's in
sensory science similar just a little
bit more intense in the middle one we
smelled hops that were harvested
September 1st September 4th and
September 7th and they were markedly
different Grossman is a pioneer in the
craft beer movement this has to be very
different from what it was like when you
first came here in the 7 News it is when
he first came to Yakima Grossman says it
was pretty much a one hop town with the
crop used mostly for bittering so what
changed well we started focusing on a
hop back seed the hop right behind is
called cascade in our Pale Ale in 1980
in the decades to follow craft brewers
began to focus on the unn
potential of other varieties so there's
literally thousands of different
varieties of hops these vines will
emerge and they'll go from mid May to 18
feet tall and by July 4th farmers like
Eric de Maury at CLS farms have been
growing their crops to meet the growing
demand we've tripled our size over the
last five years I mean that's amazing in
five years CLS isn't the only farm to
benefit from the industry's unquenchable
thirst for hops would you say that it
helped save some of the farms in our
area absolutely the hop industry would
have existed for sure in the Yakima
Valley but it's a more vibrant and
healthier industry now with more players
and more farmers it's a far cry from the
industry this fourth generation hops
farmer chose to enter in taking on the
family business was it something that
your family wanted you to be in the hop
industry in the 90s kind of when I
graduated from college was kind of in a
40-year secular decline and so I think
they would have preferred if I would
have did something else but I didn't
quite let them have that have that
option I kind of just nosed right in
there what we're really after is that
yellow substance and its term is called
lublin so what we like to do is get a
little heat in it do that Wow and so
every variety has a has a unique aroma
to it and so some are express themselves
as pine some express themselves citrus
that I may taste it goes at the end of
the beer yep exactly
we caught up with Demery during the busy
fall harvest which lasts about 40 days
in that time the farm is in production
24 hours a day 7 days a week 15 years
ago you would never see a brew I mean we
we'd never even have a visitor an order
through some company yeah and that
that's really dramatically changed in
six years now
Brewers like Adam Schmidt out of
Michigan make the trek to Yakima
from all over the country for us it's
imperative that we come out here the
hops that we're currently using this
year need to match the hops that are on
the vines right now and that are coming
down so that my founders always taste
like my phone exactly it's not all
business thanks to the month-long party
at Sports Center a bar in downtown
Yakima it's a chance for Brewers and
farmers to enjoy the fruits of their
labor and to talk shop
everybody getting down to business
during during the day doing hop
selection checking out farms that night
we're all going and hanging out together
and kind of seeing what new things were
all coming up with not everybody was
interacting with the farmers and getting
getting to know the people that were
growing their ingredients yeah but they
still felt the the connection with the
hops and that's kind of where everything
grew it's well we're putting these in
our beer so we need to come out and see
what's going on and and meet these
people the dramatic growth in demand our
hops these farms
over the past decade it has slowed down
a bit there's nothing really to do with
hops but make beer so when there's
excess hops it's very problematic when
there's too many hops the price crashes
very quickly which is effective because
it sends the messages to stop producing
but Demery says there are indications
the craft beer phenomenon will go global
we see four or five years of a little
bit of ruggedness and in the market it
appears there's gonna be a nice runway
there for for a lot of years and so
Yakima Washington and this Yakima Valley
will be at the center of it all yes
absolutely this this will continue to be
the dominant growing region for CBS this
morning Saturday Dana Jacobson Moxie
Washington Wow
I mean thank you hops for making my beer
so delicious that's a time that I wish
the beer coverage beat Oh Dana the beer
beat